[Applause]
[Music]
there you are
you've been selected to play
hi
right come right up here wow you are
really giving me 50 first dates vibes i
wore like that pink shirt and the white
jeans the entire movie
i know are you are you are you good i'll
be i'll be okay
all right you're paying attention to the
show right i'm trying my best okay okay
christina if you answer three questions
correctly about today's show that's a
thousand dollars but it's a hundred
bucks for every question answered right
so here we go all right first question
who canceled on me this morning
somebody called me this morning or
texted me and was like i'm not coming
and i was like yes
personal trainer my trainer called this
morning and canceled
me so worried
it was kind of a trick question because
i cancelled culture you know i got a
little confused by that tail okay all
right that's one
correct answer next question
why did drew congratulate the estefans
they were nominated for emmy and the
first season too congratulations on
getting a season two we all got
nominated for emmys
this is so exciting
okay it comes down to this last question
for a thousand
dollars
christina
how many friends does oprah have
[Applause]
when it comes to friends the magic
number is three
thank you everybody so much for choosing
to spend your time with us we make this
show for you so please take this good
energy with you and hopefully we'll see
you again
[Applause]
[Music]